right hot well cheer about let's do this
[ __ ] and she is hot as a Jamaican
beauties I heard about this expedition
of yours we need you please turn back
the whole strong and one more rifle
won't make a difference mainlander if
the red deaths real I'm that all I've
seen in fig don't say you haven't been
warned uh-huh I can [ __ ] yeah one hot
lady well I gotta say that's right at
the island yeah this man very che but
she not come with me
the [ __ ] is she
alright this suck not again [ __ ] good
I've been swindled for the last time ok
man
a mariner [ __ ] left you read me
mainlander yeah I guess I plotted a safe
course for your vote don't tamper with
it the shoals near where we're headed
can easily capsize a vote of your side
I'll catch up to you
and you know a [ __ ] is that much further
mainlander you tell me a mail antigen
Stacey told others have her brush with
the Red Death they laughed at her then
two weeks after a full fishing you
wearing a mother map oh [ __ ] actually
kind of far off never came back from the
beach they saw the glow on the horizon
I've been looking to end the reign of
the Red Death Tara I hope that we're
gonna [ __ ] hit it wreck all around it
itch
there
right meet you there and get prepared
hey
where is my compadre huh
[ __ ] around time
okay this read it can't be that's the
Red Death what the [ __ ] eyes shut
think we can handle it we could always
call in the Marines oh haha what do we
say to all the we tell them the truth
will be maybe we embellish I have little
stomach for let's go I didn't think it
would turn out okay okay
hello
how he did it wasn't supposed to be like
this
that's kind of [ __ ] up a fun chat
mashantucket with right funny
aired rocket
yeah this guy's a lot clearer after that
ok
that's hilarious
yes yes Eva heroes walk that's dead baby
let's [ __ ] do it
yeah thank you shut up their back did
you find it began the scourge of the
Seas oh uh we set sail it was a terrible
thought so you killed it oh yes we did
that it was a know what that up down the
street here they did it the red that's
no more dude take long my grandpa get it
would take a mini Newt direct to the
center of the eye to do it in not would
it work but we may do a C's are ours
again huh fish piece tell me are you
injured Mariner are you okay no we
managed to get through unscathed thank
God I thought for sure you were asleep
I'm sure your graves here's to the
heroes I'm scream dad okay thank you
sticks out for her Amish
Oh